euh alors on va pas Guillaume chez
Guillaume j'ai mis de chez vous
maintenant oui c'est vrai
[Rires]
si tu devais dormir chez un chroniqueurs
ce serait chez qui
n'hésite pas chez Gilles
beaucoup chez Gilles même s'il gueule
beaucoup
alors attends attends
il va dire Delphine alors j'aurais dit
Delphine mais si c'est vraiment pour
m'installer vraiment à l'aise et tout ça
peut-être Géraldine je veux pas je veux
pas jeûner les gens et je sais qu'on est
plus proche et Géraldine ah ouais ah
ouais
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
avec plaisir ma Gégé tu viendrais
franchement
Bernards
laisse tomber je vais y aller
non mais vas-y non mais sérieux si
j'aime beaucoup c'est comme ça me
rappelle un truc ça y est des années là
je suis avec un copain il y a 15 20 ans
j'avais 12 ans 11 ans enfin j'avais
enfin
parce que Raymond peut rigoler sur cette
vanne franchement il y a longtemps je
vous jure que c'est vrai on rentre et il
y a et ça me rappelle c'est vraiment
j'avais l'impression d'être dans une
scène des Bronzés je suis avec de mon
copain à copain à moi
et des indices partout
on rentre et on est avec une jeune fille
sympathique tu vois elle a elle on va
chez une copie tout ça on va armurer
pour prendre un petit verre pas de
problème et là et là il y a les
escaliers et il y a l'ascenseur et je
suis habite à étage ta copine 5 et elle
dit bon ben moi je prends l'ascenseur et
là mon pote il fait vachement cher vas-y
vas-y prends les escaliers toi vas-y
là c'est complet là vas-y dégage
ça me rappelle ça en fait tu vois voilà
toi tu dormais chez qui Francesca ah
mais pourquoi parce que on se connaît
depuis des années il y aurait aucune
ambiguïté je sais que je serais bien
accueilli chez elle ouais moi aussi il
faut être très important
absolument non mais c'est vrai Francesca
euh bah moi j'irai chez Géraldine parce
que je trouve qu'elle me cadrerait ah
ouais ouais j'aime bien pourquoi
[Rires]
chez moi
pas mal non pourquoi non pourquoi parce
que en fait en ce moment il a besoin de
rééquilibrage alimentaire et si on
habitait ensemble
[Applaudissements]
c'est plutôt ça pour se faire bouffer le
maïs
me de faire du pop-corn que de manger du
Quino et vous si vous étiez obligé de
choisir un chroniqueur pour dormir
pendant une semaine vous avez aucune
solution
j'ai toujours eu le rêve américain
aux États-Unis donc forcément j'irai
voilà quoi
la journée moi la journée
serait de la petite femme et la nuit je
sais pas grosse biatch oh
il y a un petit côté dedans alors hahaha
mais si vous ne pouvez pas vous allez
chez Béa non non non non
il y a son mari je vais te déranger ça
va moi je vous accueille avec plaisir
alors moi j'ai reçu Jean-Marie je pense
ah très bien ça c'est un bon choix
on les enferme dans la chambre mais tout
le reste de l'appartement on peut jouer
à la console et tout j'adore j'adore
toutes les permissions et ben toi tu
irais dormir chez qui toi ben moi
j'irais bien chez toi parce que je suis
jamais venu ah bah tu peux venir
tout le monde est allé non un jour vous
devriez faire un grand dîner avec toute
l'équipe chez vous comme ça
[Rires]
mais j'étais pas bien alors donc tu
parles de ce que tu connais pas donc tu
te permets de juger l'injugeable je vois
pas vivre dans un endroit
tu sais je vais te dire moi ma personne
elle est comme mon pied j'ai pas besoin
d'une chaussure trop grande une
chaussure à ma taille ça me suffit
[Applaudissements]